Bentornati a una puntata di Cucina
Buttata. Ho bisogno in realtà di una
musica di pathos, ho bisogno di Mission
Impossible come...come effetto perché finalmente
*musica Mission Impossible imitata male*
No non ho bisogno di Mission Impossible. Tipo trailer...
Finalmente ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi, ho cercato
ovunque su internet per trovare la
ricetta della vita: il gelato da fare in casa in cinque
minuti! Ennio Morricone, grazie per le vostre
armonie. Ho trovato una ricetta, grazie a
fanpage e ad altri siti americani che
spiegano come fare il gelato in cinque
minuti. Se funziona io ho trovato la
svolta. Io voglio solamente commenti di
"Grazie"
Lasciateci sotto il numero di telefono del dottor Nowzaradan (Chef Rico)
"Lasciateci sotto ogni speranza o voi che entrate"
Se veramente questa ricetta funziona
stiamo nella fantascienza, a cavallo
Posso avere un nitrito...Mamma mia.
Mazza bravo (Chef Rico).
Un'unione fra un cavallo e una strega
Non ridere se questo è quello che la
felicità ti causa
Per fare il gelato in cinque minuti avremo bisogno di... un gelato (Rico)...un gelato. Latte, panna
fresca, zucchero, gocce di cioccolato e basta! basta!
In realtà avremo bisogno anche di
questi sacchettini, del sale grosso e di ghiaccio
Ma sicuro che viene fuori un gelato? (Rico)... No. Ti ho convinto? ... *tosse*... Hai fatto?
Prendiamo questo misuratore factotum,
perché con questo coso ci abbiamo fatto
qualsiasi cosa. 100 grammi di latte
fresco intero. Aspetta qui non c'è la
tacca dei 100, quindi devo farlo ad occhio.
Cioè è assurdo che sia così facile fare
questo gelato. No è assurdo!  Gli ingredienti sono alla fine latte, panna (Rico)...Si ma, aspetta il momento dopo
perché quella è la follia. Altri 100 grammi,
di panna. La mano di un chirurgo vorrei
semplicemente dire. 40 grammi di
zucchero. Mazza 40, ragazzi oggi è tutto...cioè
Ora secondo me la cosa migliore che consiglio è
utilizzare una bustina più piccola e una
più grande, perché poi questa bustina
piccola dovrà entrare in quella più
grande per raffreddarsi. Ve lo faccio
vedere dopo. Quindi prendiamo la
bustina piccola. E' rimasto tutto lo zucchero qua dentro
Perché l'hai messo là dentro? (Rico)... Rimettilo (Mario)
Mamma mia sembra un preservativo usato (Rico). Che schifo!
E' divertente? (Rico)... Molto, vuoi provare? Dà
soddisfazione. Prendiamo delle gocce di
cioccolato e mettiamocene qb, quanto basta. Guglielmo il grembiule! (Rico)...Ah oddio grembiule
Non so come indossarlo questa volta. Vediamo se così funziona. Choccolade
Cioè qb è... ok credo di aver  esagerato
No è solo cioccolato. No aspetta questo m'esplode. Non fate il palloncino
come ho fatto io. Io spero che funzioni,
sono veramente curioso
qb rioso (Rico)...Lo sai che ho
pensato alla stessa battuta, e ho pensato
"Non la dico perché è una m***a", e invece c'è qualcuno che ha avuto il coraggio
Prendiamo a questo punto la busta più grande
apriamola, e riempiamola di ghiaccio
Bravissimo! (Rico)...Enrico, tu subito che vieni qui a
inquadrare il disastro eh? Grazie
Stai rovinando il cucino (Rico)...la cucina del cugino, il cucino
Almeno capito? Sono pronto! Posso dire che
invece con questo colore "chic"
Scusate qui facciamo anche moda...Sono piccoli quei guanti credo (Rico)
A me hai ispirato criminalità con quei guanti (Mario)
Criminalità? A me tiporoba...Topolino (Rico). Ragazzi c'è una grande differenza fra criminalità e Topolino
Prendiamo il sale grosso e lo buttiamo
dentro. Ora teoricamente il sale insieme
al ghiaccio creano una reazione per cui
la temperatura all'interno di questo
sacchetto dovrebbe abbassarsi ulteriormente
E' come se il sale tirasse fuori il ghiaccio glaciale del ghiaccio...il meglio del ghiaccio (Rico)
Il meglio del ghiaccio grazie. Infiliamo il
nostro sacchetto, chiudiamo per 5 minuti
soltanto dovremmo teoricamente
massaggiare il tutto "così"
Delicatamente col terrore che esploda da
un momento all'altro...Non so nemmeno se
si è bucato o no il sacchetto. Vuoi un cambio? Gu è sicuramente bucato. Non lo girare non lo girare!
Eh vabbè vuoi il cambio, voglio il cambio. Quanto manca? Ok. Ma dai che cos'è?! No. Dov'è il coso per
asciugare. Il tempo è alquanto relativo (Mario).
Si beh il tempo è relativo...Madonna Gu (Rico)
Oddio scusatemi. Vabbé facciamo altri cinque minuti abbiamo detto?
Il sale viene messo sulla neve per farla sciogliere
Quando a Roma nevica ci mettono il sale, così la neve si scioglie. Non mi torna
allora questo. Possiamo vedere su
internet perché si mette il sale nella neve?
almeno facciamo anche informazione. Il
gelato sta diventando più scuro, prima
era proprio bianco e adesso invece sta
prendendo un colorito, sono daltonico
"I singoli cristalli di ghiaccio smettono di costituirsi grazie agli ioni di sale"
Evita che si ghiacci la neve...eh, che si ghiacci...però molti lo usano per liberare le
strade (Mario). Ma perché mettono il sale sulla neve e diventa gelato (Rico)
e passano tipo...passando di ingordi. Proviamo a
vedere che cosa è uscito?
Oh!...Oh!...Oh!
Cioè è goccioline di cioccolato e gelato ma di
base è venuta na mezza m***a, si possiamo dirlo
tranquillamente. Ritorniamo ai lustri di sempre, due
ricette andate bene, si ritorna a creare
roba abominevole
Le dosi erano giuste! Vabbè la certezza è
che sei tornato sui classici binari
di Cucina Buttata...Cioè?...Una m***a! (Mario).
Non era cattivo, era semplicemente molto molto
molto acquoso. Scusate se qualcuno
proverà a fare questa cosa, ok a casa sua
anche se io lo sconsiglio caldamente,
fatemi sapere cosa avete fatto di
fantasmagorico se vi riuscirà.
Taggatemi su Instagram, taggatemi nelle
vostre stories, taggatemi nei vostri post,
fate quello che vi pare, l'importante è
che qualcuno che conosca un metodo
veloce per fare il gelato a casa senza
bisogno della gelatiera, me lo faccia
sapere qua sotto. Come sempre vi invito ad
attivare la campanella per venire
aggiornati ogni volta che uscirà un
nuovo video e che dire... io vi invito a a non farlo (RIco).
Che brutta cosa sapere che domani non
vedrai l'alba di un nuovo giorno...
Noi ci vediamo la prossima settimana con
un'altra ricetta. Ciao grazie mille. Ragazzi  io intanto alla
faccia vostra me lo finisco. Tranquillo non ti invidiamo affatto, finisci pure (Chef Mario)